y pues después de esta reunión que duró
tres horas la Casa Blanca publicó un
comunicado en el que dice que pues no
sería bueno para para la prosperidad del
mundo y para la prosperidad de la región
que los conflictos sigan creciendo en el
estrecho de Taiwán Estados Unidos en el
comunicado de la Casa Blanca que él
sigue sigue firme en el estatus de una
china y no quiere que el estatus quo
precisamente cambie En cuanto a Taiwán
que eso no le Sería bueno para la región
ni para el mundo resaltó además que
quiere mantener un canal de comunicación
abierto entre los dos países
precisamente para abordar uno de estos
puntos principales que se tocaron en
esta reunión a Puerta cerrada de tres
horas que fuese el de Taiwán y el futuro
de las relaciones entre taiwari y China
y Cristóbal uno de los otros puntos que
ambos abordaron fue esta guerra
comercial y es que hace personas la Casa
Blanca incrementó los controles para la
exportación de tecnología estadounidense
hacia China para la producción de chips
Washington tiene intención de detener
esta guerra comercial
pues no parece que haya una intención
Aunque a puertas para afuera el gobierno
de Estados Unidos sigue diciendo que
quiere mantener un diálogo que quiere
encontrar un punto en común para que
este esta diferencia comercial no escale
a una diferente a una conflicto bélico
pues la Casa Blanca precisamente dice
que ellos van a seguir compitiendo
vigorosamente y fue una palabra que que
dijo el comunicado vigorosamente no
solamente fortaleciendo las fuentes
internas para su tecnología sino también
haciendo alianzas estratégicas con
aliados precisamente para competir con
china sin embargo la Casa Blanca también
mencionó que está abierto a tratar de
encontrar procedimientos mutuos para que
este conflicto comercial no siga
escalando y pues dijo que era importante
también pues a seguir con reuniones
después de esta reunión bilateral con
reuniones de funcionarios chinos y
estadounidenses de hecho pues la Casa
Blanca anunció esta reunión de los dos
líderes el secretario de estado Anthony
viajará a China las próximas semanas
para reunirse con una delegación China y
pues avanzar en este sentido